en novembre dernier une femme décide de
porter plainte pour viol contre Harry
habitant un acteur de 47 ans a été placé
en garde à vue selon le Journal du
Dimanche l'acteur de qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait au bon Dieu aurait été confronté il
y a quelques jours dans le bureau du
juge à sa victime présumée j'ai toujours
été prévenant avec les femmes à l'écoute
je consomme mais toujours de manière
authentique et vraie mais cette
révélation n'est pas la seule fête par
le JDD qui nous apprend que deux autres
femmes auraient témoignées dans ce
dossier parmi elles une comédienne qui
affirme que l'acteur aurait eu des
gestes déplacer lors d'un tournage alors
qu'elle se changeait derrière un
paravent il me touchait de partout on
aurait dit qu'il avait 1000 mains les
seins évidemment les bras j'avais
l'effet d'un mille pattes sur moi
l'autre femme qui témoigne prétend de
son côté carry habitant l'aurait invité
chez lui puis embrassé sur la bouche
avant d'aller plus loin il a mis sa main
dans mon pantalon je me suis écarté lui
les judices à aller trop vite pour moi
que ce n'était pas ce que je voulais à
Ferrari habitants confrontation et
nouveautés dans le cadre de l'enquête
pour viol toutes les informations dans
TPMP
merci Myriam
Myriam journaliste people Myriam s'est
affaire elle n'en finit pas la Ferrari
habitant parce que en vrai et on le sait
plus la faire dure moins un habitant
reprend le travail parce que voilà si
imaginons qu'il soit demain innocenté ou
voilà et c'est vrai que ça fait combien
d'années ça fait combien de temps
maintenant que ça dure ça fait un an
puisque
les faits ont été pardon un peu plus
fort machin merci ça fait ça fait un an
puisqu'il a été inculpé pour viol le 2
novembre 2021 donc un peu moins d'un an
mis un exemple mis en examen
pardon oui donc à Ary Abittan donc la
faire
[Rires]
[Musique]
que beau il avait l'habitude de
consommer régulièrement déjà le terme
consommé voilà mais que il l'avait
toujours fait de façon authentique et
vrai il reconnaît donc avoir eu une
relation sexuelle avec la jeune
plaignante mais de ne pas l'avoir forcé
notamment dans un deuxième rapport
sexuel où il aurait été extrêmement brut
et aurait
l'aurait forcé à faire une sodomie et ce
qui est surtout une grosse claque pour
judiciaire pour arihabitant c'est que de
nouveautés ont été apportés au dossier
en fait deux personnes qui n'ont pas
elle était victime de viol et qui n'ont
pas porté plainte apporte le témoignage
sur un comportement brutal dont une
actrice notamment qui rapporte des faits
du diable est-ce que dans ces cas là
aussi il y a pas ce que tu Mathieu des
gens voilà qui qui disent voilà un jour
il a fait un truc voilà et qui viennent
se greffer au dossier
plusieurs contexte comme ça ça n'a
aucune valeur
et les jeunes femmes
je le connais pas et personnellement je
suis contente de balconet mais
c'est vrai que on y arrive elle arrête
pas depuis tout à l'heure mais alors non
mais non mais voilà
mon ami donc je vous raconte les choses
de façon factuelle de des choses qu'il y
a dans le dossier l'effet qu'elle
rapporte sont assez sont assez quand
même flagrants alors il y a déjà une
actrice qui raconte que sur le tournage
d'un film alors qu'elle était derrière
un paravent en petite tenue ary
habitants s'est pointé a commencé à
mettre ses mains sur ses seins sur son
ventre etc là-dessus elle l'aurait
repoussé et là il se serait crié ah
ouais 0 0 humour on va bien s'amuser
avec toi petite [ __ ] voilà c'est ce
qu'elle raconte et puis elle raconte
aussi un deuxième fait c'est que pendant
le tournage d'une scène il lui aurait
mis le pied entre dans entre enfin dans
l'entrejambe alors là elle aurait
explosé elle l'aurait poussé aurait
piqué un pédales devant toute l'équipe
de tournage et ary abitance ce serait
défendu en la traitant de folle et en
lui disant qu'il voulait juste enlever
sa chaussure parce qu'il avait chaud au
pied donc voilà et
je pense comme une autre
et par la suite elle aurait été reçu
hyper normal dans la mesure où juste
avant il a quand même flotté derrière un
paravent et qu'elle l'a recompté il a
insulté donc c'est pas du viol mais ça
peut être quand même une agression
sexuelle quand une femme elle a pas
envie qu'on la touche sur les seins et
le ventre c'est voilà
pour se défendre face aux enquêteurs
spontanés c'est-à-dire que c'est des
témoignages
c'est des témoignages je pense spontanés
en fait elles se sont manifestées fin
août auprès des policiers de du 1er
département de police judiciaire et
elles ont apporté leur témoignages en
disant que voilà et elles avaient été
sensible au témoignages de la de la
victime présumée de viol et qu'elles
avaient envie voilà de de la défendre et
de et de comprendre aussi que de faire
comprendre que c'était pas une folle
furieuse qui a inventé des choses en
fait tout ça trace un portrait d'arrêt
habitant très négatif voilà la teneur de
là il y a des témoignages positifs aussi
non la teneur de l'article
est assez à charge alors rappelons qu'il
est présumé innocent et pour répondre à
votre question Cyril sur la
confrontation on avait dit vous souvenez
au début que ce serait très long ce sera
très long c'est à dire que s'il y a un
procès ce sera évidemment pas avant 2023
et je dirais on se demande même si ce
sera en 2023 ça va être très long le
juge voulait prendre son temps pour que
la plaignante comment elle va l'appeler
alors la feignante elle va pas bien
parce que déjà elle a elle a eu 10 jours
10 tt suite à des plaies sur enfin des
hématos psychologiquement les
commentaires alors psychologiquement
elle est elle serait victime de de
commencer avec un syndrome
post traumatique sévère et du coup elle
irait extrêmement mal elle sait toujours
pas remise de cette affaire et ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été constaté quand
même par le médecin de l'unité
médico-judiciaire elle ne se manifeste
pas on a eu son avocat qui refuse de
donner toute information de parler le
juge impose un strict secret à tout le
monde aux deux parties et c'est vrai que
elle voulait cette confrontation s'il y
avait confrontation le plus tard
possible parce que son avocat craignait
qu'en face d'Harry habitants son
témoignage soit fragilisés voilà donc
on va dire qu'un statu quo il y a un
statu quo lui maintient que c'est
consenti les deux rapports et elle comme
disait Myriam le deuxième rapport est
forcé voilà comment prouver qu'une
relation sexuelle
alors il y a quand même des rapports le
rapport médical qui dit quand même qu'il
y a des lésions assez graves au niveau
du excusez moi du terme du vagin et de
l'anus qui ont entraîné voilà 10 jours
d'été et qui ont montré qu'il y avait eu
des rapports sexuels brutaux alors c'est
vrai qu'on se dit tout ce qu'on aura le
fin mot de l'histoire Gilles Verdez ou
lui dites 2024 pour vous 2023 plutôt
mais c'est très lent parce que
effectivement là ils sont en train de
tracer le portrait de la réhabitant
savoir exactement s'il y a d'autres
choses ou pas donc l'instruction et
extrêmement lente voilà c'est pas un
jugement mais ça va très doucement et
surtout il y a eu un deuxième témoignage
ou qui est assez assez éloquant mais il
y a surtout dans ce deuxième témoignage
un truc assez bizarre ou en fait la
jeune femme raconte que après avoir été
embrassé de force par Ary Abittan et
l'avoir repoussé il lui aurait il aurait
été voilà alors ça va vous faire rire
mais il a été chercher du linge et s'est
mis à le plier devant elle et lui aurait
expliqué qu'en fait il avait des
troubles obsessionnels compulsifs et du
coup il suffit de regarder un peu dans
les archives dans lors d'une interview à
Victor a dit qu'il était qu'il souffrait
d'une phobie
d'impulsion qui en fait une phobie où on
a toujours peur de passer à l'acte donc
ça peut aussi éclairer sur le
comportement
obsessionnel d'arrêt habitant et cette
facilité qu'il a à croire que les femmes
dans la mesure où elle lui parle ont
envie soit de coucher avec lui soit
d'être dragué par lui
il risque quoi après on aura à Guillaume
qu'il y a d'autres 15 ans de prison
c'est aussi pour ça les enjeux sont
énormes c'est aussi pour ça que le juge
veut établir l'ensemble des faits il y a
deux versions totalement contradictoires
donc voilà il y a ary habitants qui
maintient les deux rapports consentis et
des expertises pour la plaignante
qui n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer en rond
il y a une source proche du dossier qui
nous a livré des informations sur cette
fameuse confrontation donc la victime
présumée faut savoir qu'elle travaille
dans le milieu audiovisuel dans le
milieu du cinéma plus particulièrement
arrêtons si cette excusé auprès d'elle
sur la violence de l'acte et pour les
séquelles physiques et psychiatriques
qu'il a causé il faut savoir qu'elle a
eu 15 jours 10 tt sur l'option
psychiatrique ce qui est très rare 15
jours dit tt donc ils ne regrette de pas
avoir abordé ce sujet avec elle pendant
la relation parce qu'il dit en gros
voilà on a eu un rapport sexuel un peu
bestial on aurait pu en parler pendant
la relation et lui il l'a pensé que
c'était consenti au moment des faits il
risquerait donc 15 le printemps de
réclusion criminelle pour viol avec
violence qui est énorme voilà on va
consenti dans le témoignage elle dit
quand même qu'elle a crié plusieurs fois
qu'elle a dit trois fois non
en revanche en tout cas
juste est-ce que est-ce que ça compagne
continue à le soutenir elle continue
elle continue à le soutenir malgré tout
malgré le fait que quand même il est
finalement trompé puisque cette relation
a eu lieu alors que il était avec elle
depuis plusieurs années
pointe au commissariat chaque semaine et
cet été il y a eu quelques photos qui
sont sorties justement pour montrer
qu'il tente et veut entre guillemets
reprendre une vie normale